oh mein gott nein
millionen von spielern haben bereits von
epic games eine e-mail bekommen mit der
sie sich fort eine battle royale auf
ihren handys herunterladen können und
dann gibt es noch nicht ich habe noch
keine e mail bekommen
[Musik]
du bastard das ganze mit ford auf dem
iphone sonst aber gar nicht so krass
juden ich meine dann kommt die mehrheit
morgen oder übermorgen hoffentlich
endlich mal an wir spielen nämlich heute
mal wieder fort nicht auf dem pc
wir gehen wir wieder zur retail wohin
allerdings freunde wir haben heute eine
challenge am start in einem meiner
letzten videos habe ich euch gefragt
freunde habt ihr richtig bock darauf das
habe ich mir überlegen weil ich das noch
nicht so richtig glaube ich auf youtube
gefunden aber vielleicht bin ich einfach
auf dem falschen kanälen unterwegs so
ein bisschen fortnight challenges zu
machen und ja okay mir ist aufgefallen
dass machen schon viele leute fordern
challenges zum us-markt aber im
endeffekt niemand ich habe derzeit
leider keine zeit dafür irgendwie andere
youtuber zuschauen das einzige wo ich
mal reinschauen ist war bei ninja in den
stream oder so aber freunde ich hab ich
schon waffen auf bin ich dumm die
challenges heute dass wir ohne waffen
ins finale kommen was das heißt dass ich
halt nur irgendwelche sachen mitnehmen
darf die jetzt nicht irgendwelche
pistolen oder maschinengewehre oder
sniper oder raketenwerfer sind oder so
also ich darf hier wirklich nur fallen
und so weiter
mein ziel ist gerade so ein bisschen
mehr einfach ganz ganz viele ressourcen
zu holen so dass die einem finale
zumindest eine festung bauen kann
übrigens finale heißt für mich dass ich
unter den letzten zwei lebenden bin
das soll das ziel in dieser runde seien
freunde ich weiß allerdings wirklich
nicht ob das sind irgendeiner form
irgendwas wird weil freunde ohne waffen
wie soll ich irgend jemand töten das
beste was mir gerade gegen die passieren
kann ist halt ein busch oder soll man
nicht mehr zu kehren diese rot flinte
mitnehmen
mit dem bus könnte ich mich halt relativ
gut verstecken vor den leuten dann im
finale und könnte quasi einfach irgendwo
um kämen und dann halt versuchen ob ich
den irgendwie irgendwo runterschubsen
kann oder keine ahnung was aber dafür
muss sich halt doch erst mal ins finale
kommen ich will hier mit wirklich keiner
anderen youtuber irgendwie nach machen
oder serien clown falls irgendwelche
amerikanischen schon irgendwie eine
serie haben wo die vorteile challenges
machen oder irgendwie sowas also ich
habe mir nur gedacht okay das klingt
eigentlich relativ cool mal schauen ob
ich damit zurecht komme und ich denke er
nicht
ich habe wohingegen wo eine kiste gehört
aber ich weiß nicht genau wo die armen
gottfried zu bitten neuen sturmgewehren
selten
das hier ist eine fernseh und ladung
okay
mal schauen ob ich damit irgendwie was
reißen kann aber freund bin ich
überhaupt ja okay ich bin zumindest in
der zone
da hinten ist ein gegner blind auf mein
mann und ich kann nichts machen gegen
ihn wenn ich mit meiner ersten runde
fort so angucke wie ich da gespielt habe
allein das nicht wahr das ist eine sache
von sekunden das ist das ist wow wow
cool ich liebe dieses spiel was sonst
kommen die kurse hoch und spaß aber
jetzt gerade muss ich halt mich so ein
bisschen älter hier liegen echt
vernünftige sachen eigentlich dafür dass
das hier so am arsch der welt ist luca
getötet wegen viel besser sachen ja aber
wie soll ich bildet überleben ohne
waffen
ein paar sekunden später nein nein ich
wurde 28
und man das war der die fohlen gesehen
habt habe ich menschen ist entsetzlich
abstoßen der zugang ist gar am start
also klar natürlich holt er mich hat
jetzt gerade eine mauer bauen kann aber
ich wüsste auch nicht fasst dann werde
ich den kriegen können das geilste wer
halt wirklich irgendwie bush gewesen
oder so ich werde in dieser runde jetzt
mal versuchen wir in dem wald hier vorne
also ein rating wurde irgendwie ein paar
vernünftige sachen holen da kann ich
mich halt zur not auch noch ganz gut
verstecken hier unten liegt direkt eine
blaue pumpgun drin freunde aber ich darf
mir die sachen halt nicht nehmen das ist
ja voll die scheiße aber zumindest man
trank hier
unschön den trank hier rein ball an so
haben wir die sachen am start
und jetzt ich weiß nicht da unten sind
auch meistens trucks oder irgendwo da wo
sind die nähe davon sind die die blaue
pumpgun werde so geil gewesen und spaß
da würde ich direkt nach vorne zu diesem
labyrinth hinlaufen und gegen welche
leute killen aber okay ich rede so als
wäre ich ein guter spieler bin ich nicht
in der tat sonst ist auf dem truck halt
irgendwie meine kiste drauf jetzt gerade
allerdings anscheinend nicht schauen wir
mal hier vornherein ob irgend was drin
ist darf ich halt alles nicht mitnehmen
was ne scheiße ich hoffe natürlich auch
in dieser runde auch irgendwie ein bus
oder so damit ich mich vernünftig
verstecken kann
das ding ist halt auch dass ich solo
spiele und nicht du also da könnte man
halt noch mit anderen und können sich
dann relativ schnell irgendwelche mauern
bauen
es liegen überall waffen herum und ich
darf die einfach nicht nehmen
hier oben haben wir wenigstens eine
kiste freunde dh mal schauen ob wir hier
gegen den burschen haben oder irgendwie
sowas wir haben stein wir haben noch ein
schild tragen
wow erstmal deppen
wenn ihr euch mal die zone anguckt seht
ihr schon dass ich nicht gerade sehr
sehr krass am rand bewege ich versuche
jetzt einfach wirklich sofort zu gehen
dass sich hieraus ein paar ressourcen
holen und mich dann immer weiter nach
innen arbeiter spielt ihr eigentlich
selbst vor ort leiten schreibt man die
kommentare auch welche battle fahrstufe
ihr seid uns was also ich glaub ich bin
gerade 740 oder irgendwie so ich bin in
letzter zeit krass fiel am
vorproduzieren weil freundlich weiß ich
wenn ihr das video hier seht aber ich
bin vom 19 03
bis 28 in miami urlaub machen ultra
music festival sind wir und so weiter
und so fort kann jetzt kam ein bisschen
reden ist gerade hier relativ langweilig
war auch freunde der epische
schrotflinte alter komme ich nehme jetzt
einfach mal mit freunde ich werde
allerdings nicht benutzten gegen
irgendwelche gegner also ich meine wenn
ich zum inventar habt dann ist das ja
nicht primär dass die benutze ich hatte
das vorhin bei den sachen eigentlich
auch so machen können dass ich dir
einfach mitnehmen damit die zumindest
kein anderer irgendwie kriegt und dann
benutze ich dir halt einfach nicht aber
so weit habe ich natürlich wieder nicht
gedacht da ich in den letzten tagen halt
wirklich immer bis vier und acht video
produziert habe ich halt nicht so viel
fordert spielen können aber ich würde
sagen dass mittlerweile eigentlich
relativ gut geworden bin also was heißt
relativ gut ich bin jetzt nicht so krass
wie in red oder wie ninja oder wien mit
oder so aber dass ich zumindest ein paar
siege holen kann
bevor noch eine kiste freunde oh mein
gott wir haben einen busch freude das
ist nicht wahr schaut euch das an
es ist gerade deutlich einfacher
geworden ich werde mich jetzt einfach
mal hier in richtung dass die depot
bewegen so dass ich relativ mittig vom
sturm bilden die vorne haben wir noch
eine grüne pumpgun nämlich nehmen die
man auch einfach mit zusatz zumindest
ich denke wird jetzt auch keinen
computer vorne sind leute freunde ich
bewege mich jetzt mal ganz langsam um
sein dings rum und bleibt zwischendurch
mal kurz stehen damit er denkt dass ich
halte mein gott nein nein
wahrscheinlich sind deine eltern nichts
zu finden
hier vorne fliegt der bus lang meine
damen und herren das heißt ich würde
sagen machen mal ein bisschen action
jetzt mal hier für die letzte runde
enthüllte towers ich weiß allerdings
nicht genau wann nicht als rausspringen
soll die meisten springen habe ich jetzt
schon irgendwie raus sondern kommen dann
springe ich jetzt auch mal alle einig
direkte falschem aufmachen okay
vielleicht macht hätte doch nicht so
viel sinn wenn da gerade so viel oder so
lara gut freunde für die letzte runde
machen wir hier mal ein bisschen action
ich meine die challenge von eis und es
hat spaß gemacht aber es hat nicht so
richtig funktioniert also es war aber
auch jetzt will man muss es sagen es ist
sehr sehr schwierig gewesen ich finde
dieses haus wie vorne ist einfach völlig
anderer rated also ich finde eigentlich
echt ganz oder teilweise für sachen drin
sind hier kann man direkt haben hier
entlang laufen wir hier vorne oben haben
wir hier nur munition also nicht sogar
die hier ist nur scheiße diese chance
jetzt wirklich nur scheiße darin kann
ich nur hoffen dass ich unten noch
irgendwas besseres haben danach werde
ich mal direkt den trank trinken hier so
die pumpgun kann man auf jeden fall
schon mal mitnehmen erstmal den trank
rheinbahn es bringt das mal bitte ein
bisschen schneller und direkt noch einen
fetten trank hinterher der das erstmal
auf 75 hoch baller das ist doch schön
freunde hier vorne ein bisschen holz
können wir noch mitnehmen so wundervoll
will ihr vielleicht irgendwas geiles
sein wie gesagt das haus ist total
andere rated hier sind noch verbände
drin hier ist ein bisschen metall hier
ist eine kiste kommt bitte gib mir
irgendwas ok wenigstens was ethisch ist
auch mit der pistole ist wollen ich
werde jetzt einfach mal riskieren
ich werde jetzt mal einfach hier
irgendwie ihr überlaufen ich bin
gespannt ob ich das schaffen werde ob
ich das überleben werde aber ich bin
hier angekommen und jetzt will ich
natürlich wieder runter das ist es
hinten spannend man hört auf jeden fall
dass hier einige leute drin sind
was war das das ist was ist denn mit dir
fall schalter einfach mal die treppe
kaputtmachen ok digger jetzt komme ich
dann natürlich gerade nicht wiederholt
es war das denn alter schildow von allen
seiten ihr kommen gerade irgendwelche
schüsse aber ich muss mich erst mal ganz
kurz orientieren wo ich hier gerade
überhaupt bin also soll hier mal kurz
eben wieder hoch wo kommen wir denn
jetzt mal hier lang ein paar sekunden
später film wie stressig dass hier
gerade ist erstmal schnell medicaid
rhein waal an m ich bin gespannt ob ich
davor nicht schon abgeknallt werden von
dem typen der hier um die ecke kommt ich
muss mich jetzt mal ganz kurz zu
organisieren um mal eben kurz die den
zehn sekunden rang reinwand oh mein gott
ist tot
alter schwede freunde ich muss mal ganz
kurz eben klar kommen nein jetzt nur
besser ich habe mit allen märz ich hatte
irgendwie viele leute noch getötet alter
lasst mich doch nicht organisieren
das war's jetzt allerdings auch hiervon
wieder meine damen und herren die
challenge hat nicht so gut geklappt die
runde jetzt gerade hätte ich glaube ich
ganz gut gewinnen können aber also ich
sage einen guten lauf aber dann kommt
dieser typ hat aus dem fenster wenn ihr
euch das ganze gefallen hat das gerne
mal ein leica schreibt mir andere
challenges in die kommentare wo ihr
sagen würdet hey luca die könntest du ja
auch vielleicht total verpacken sonst
freunde wenn ihr weiterhin fordert auf
meinem kanal sehen wollte ich weiß ich
bin ich der beste spieler aber ich mach
mich ein bisschen finde ich ändern
lassen 14.000 leichter
auch wenn die live-streams sehen wollt
könnt ihr morgen in die kommentare
schreiben und sonst würde ich an der
stelle einfach nur noch sagen dass
wasser ziehen
das war es jetzt hier vom video hier
können jetzt hier meinen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
aus checken jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auch die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]